one thing I really like about you is you
are unusually fearless and willing to go
in the face of other people telling you
something that's crazy and I know a lot
of pretty crazy people you still stand
out where does that come from or how do
you think about making a decision when
everyone tells you this is a crazy idea
where do you get the internal strength
to do that well first of all I'd say I
actually think I feel feel fair quite
strongly so it's not as though I just
have the absence of fear I've I feel it
quite strongly but there are times when
if something is important enough
you've leave it enough that you do it in
spite of the fear so speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think I I I should I should think well I
feel fear about this and therefore I
shouldn't do it it's normal to be to
feel fear like you'd have to definitely
something mentally wrong you shouldn't
feel fear so you just feel it and let
the importance of it anyway yeah you
know actually we're something that can
be helpful as fatalism some degree if
you just think it's just accept the
probabilities then that diminishes fear
so we're starting SpaceX I thought the
odds of success were less than 10% and I
just accepted that actually probably I
would just lose lose everything but that
maybe would make some progress if we
could just move the ball forward even if
we died maybe some other company could
pick up the baton and move and keep
moving it forward so that were still do
some good yeah same with Tesla I thought
your odds of a car company succeeding
were extremely low
you